sur l'un des vols en cas de besoin
voler sur le territoire des Allemands quelque chose de technicien
l'aîné qui a préparé cette voiture il
et je me souviens m'avoir étreint et embrassé
J'étais encore surpris la nuit c'est du coup une technique
il m'est venu à l'esprit d'embrasser ici et puis papa
J'ai réalisé qu'il m'avait dit au revoir parce que
ne revient pas de ces vols
mais je pensais que ma place est toujours sur
de face
J'ai demandé au commandant du régiment, il a dit non, mais
Je suis quand même allé à l'aérodrome et il y avait
l'avion qui est allé au régiment avant I
est monté à bord de cet avion et s'est envolé pour
régiment avant
[musique]
commandant de régiment au poste de commandement soudainement
J'ai demandé où il n'y a ni moi ni
Alekseeva ne s'est pas assise dedans pendant qu'ils décollaient
et s'envoler volé par l'indice de quelqu'un d'autre
aller et quand nous sommes arrivés
Shaposhnikov le commandant du régiment et nous a grondés
sans pitié que nous pouvions nous permettre
tel sur le bouclier quelqu'un hooliganisme bien sûr
année sur a frappé la table avec son poing ici
ne leur donne pas
[musique]
mari est allé se coucher puis soudain devant la fenêtre nous
entendre des coups de feu
mais étaient au deuxième étage et tant pis
ce qui s'est passé fin de la guerre guerre
terminé
ici on a vu le nôtre aussi dans la rue
a également ouvert le feu avec des pistolets
nous ne savons tout simplement pas comment le leur exprimer
sentiment pour certains tels
fou ce que c'était et je ne sais pas
rigolé
[musique]
et dit que ça ne peut pas être alors gal
aussi un record du monde, eh bien, il n'était pas
tout à fait compris
le taux de sorties pour les Américains était
25 sorties
[musique]
étui d'arbalète pour vous montrer
bien tout seul
[musique]